[Music]
the predator series is one of the most
popular alien franchises in the film
world
since the predator could not achieve the
hope for success and disney now really
doesn't stand for brutal alien action
fans did not expect too much from a
potential predator 5.
as discussing film reported at the end
of last year director dan trachtenberg
and screenwriter patrick ayson have been
working on a project called skulls for
quite some time
logically after all the predator
collects the scouts of his victims
as has now become known the upcoming
film unlike its predecessors is intended
to play in the past and not in the
present
or future allegedly this time an
american native is the center of
attention
which is not surprising because as we
know since alien vs predator
the aliens have been using the earth as
a hunting ground for a long time
a right and important impulse for the
dormant franchise
at least 10 cloverfield lane director
dan trachtenberg is not at all amused on
twitter about the leak which was
actually planned as a surprise
we'll hopefully soon find out what other
surprises trackenberg who according to
his own statement has been working on
predator for four years
has planned
[Music]
you